you're a blessing Mr Clay
this was crabgrass and weeds and you
brought it back to life
Parker and I were friends
she was like family
she was the only person who ever took
care of me
I just got a message saying that there's
a problem with my computer yes ma'am we
got this
yesterday she shot herself this is
private property do you know what they
do here scamming the weakest in our
society buddy I'm counted three one two
three
I did it for you
[Music]
I'm gonna blend this place to the ground
[Applause]
will you stomp his ass out
you're telling me one man did this
the only thing you know is is a
beekeeper
a beekeeper beekeeper well that's not
good
beekeepers is a special program outside
the chain of commands and protect the
hive when the system is out of balance
I correct it we have laws for these
things until they fail then you have me
my fingers if you cut them off oh what
the [__] bro don't move
this is much bigger than a little
fishing scam
the money's going all over the world to
people in finance even government
you are a problem God damn right I'm a
problem
no way he's coming here straight through
the back entrance I figured I'd get the
firefighters a break somebody entertain
this guy
we have to kill him before he kills his
way to the top
honey
it's flammable as [__] who knew
you're going together